j'accueille maintenant le français le
plus célèbre dans le monde depuis le
commandant cousteau est l'inventeur du
ménage à trois celui dont le nom de
famille est devenu un en commun le père
de la loue butin magna christian
louboutin
m
ça
salut question merci d'être là on s'est
connus au palace il ya plus de 35 ans
vous aviez quel âge à l'époque
j'avais 13 ans et a fait de la prison
pour sa durée
ensuite vous avez connu une réussite
hors du commun 107 boutiques dans le
monde
[Applaudissements]
mille cent cinquante mille paires de
souliers vendus chaque année par jour la
semelle rouge a conquis le monde plus
une ligne homme à la demande de votre
annie mika désolé de vous mettre la
pression mais je vais rater mon métro ce
qui est dingue c'est que les pousses de
robbie williams a couché avec de
louboutin aux pieds vous avez d'autres
exemples de louboutin magna c'est vrai
qu'il ya chez beaucoup de fans une sorte
d'addiction se met alors je me considère
aussi comme un docteur et les docteurs
ils parlent pas de leurs patientes alors
les gens viennent te voir quand j'ai un
coup de pompe hop
et alors est extraordinaire
c'est qu'elles sont pas chères
malgré votre réussite
inimaginable
vous êtes resté le même et vont toucher
le rsa alors
je te rester simple
gentille attentionnée vous êtes un amour
quand je vous appelle vous me répondez
c'est le principe de téléphone un
connard
non tu la payes tu lui dis t'as pas
sandales
c'est vrai j'aimerais vous êtes vous
êtes génial vous est d'une simplicité
extraordinaire alors ce que je vous
revois ce soir c'est qu'on reprenne les
choses au commencement d'accord
[Musique]
bonsoir un homme bon soir
comment tu t'appelles
je m'appelle christian question comment
christian louboutin c'est un mec tu ne
rêves avec un nom pareil
alors fais mal deux fois que je te
croise à la main bleue aux 7 au palace
aubin tu sors beaucoup quand même pour
ton âge n'ont qu'à quel âge de 13 ans et
demi tu veux faire quoi dans la vie je
dessinais des souliers t'as plus une
tête à vendre du fromage basque quand
même
pas quinze jours flics et au musée des
colonies tu as vu un panneau interdisant
le port des talons aiguilles qui
pouvaient rayer le parquet évidemment et
ça t'a marqué ça c'est vrai bien il ya
un dessin et puis c'est un soulier
profil et puis comme ça il est barré du
rouge mais il est barré parce que c'est
interdit 1 mais je suis pas je le
connais pas moi sous les jets jamais vu
parce que c'est très pointu c'est un
talon très fin très pointue et puis
c'est une pointe devant ce qui est
dingue c'est que depuis que tu as vu cet
escarpin sur le panneau du désign des
escarres ben oui je reproduis un peu les
mêmes et pour toi la bonne hauteur pour
untel on sait combien il sens en plateau
c'est la cambrure qui est importante
alors la cambrure quand on est une
danseuse c'est le maximum de la cambrure
ça va être 13 cm 1 si on n'est pas une
danseuse vaut mieux s'arrêter à 12
à ses membres depuis tout à l'heure je
te vois réfléchir devant ce soulier
comme ça tu penses avoir je vois que
c'est un escarpin qui doit voir plein de
couleurs et puis là quand je le vois
comme ça c'est moche il ya une masse
noire la semaine alors j'ai du vernis et
puis elle a il a une idée du prince mal
en rouge
tu veux pas ici d'autres couleurs que le
rouge là moi j'aime bien le rouge mais
est ce que quand on regarde les femmes
souvent elles disent qu'ils n'aiment pas
la couleur mais même si elle aime pas la
couleur elles ont dû rouge près l'élève
sont rouges les doigts ce oui c'est vrai
et tu te verrai faire quoi christian
aussi ça marche pas dans les souliers
j'aimerais bien écrire les scénarios bah
oui parce que j'adore écouter les gens
et j'aimerais pas faire des films parce
que je crois que c'est vachement
compliqué très mai
mais écrire des scénarios ça me paraît
j'adorerais faire ça tu te vois avant un
succès mondial non mais moi je pense pas
un succès je pense que d'abord il faut
faire les choses et puis après les
choses arrivent de manière organique
alors si ça marche très bien si ça
marche pas on peut toujours penser à
autre chose je vais te dire un truc
maintenant concentre toi est ce que tu
penses qu'un jour le nom louboutin fera
rêver toutes les femmes de la planète
par exemple quand j'en parle à mes
soeurs elles disent qu'on a un nom
vraiment moche
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus